and let's get into the reaction to what
happened from Christo groschev from the
investigative journalism group Belling
Club Bellingham good to see you on the
program thank you for your time uh today
just to tell us first about more about
vladland tatasky who was he
well I mean he's been described at this
moment primarily as a military blogger
but one has to remember that he's in
fact the soldier he's an officer in the
Russian army uh he did participate in
the Russian invasion of Ukraine in 2014
2016. he was part of the uh so-called
lugansk Republic's uh separatist Army
which was in fact controlled by the
Russian army so it was just a proxy of
the Russian military and in 2022 he was
assigned to one of the local regiments
and he has been in charge of
intelligence gathering of uh plotting
um trajectories of drones so in fact
he's a soldier who in the evening was
also a blogger so that is an important
distinction to make because this can
have a relevance as to the legitimacy of
this operation it did turn out to be an
Ukrainian operation he was known for
some extremely radical statements
including disparaging the official
Russian military forces and praising the
the private military Army Wagner he one
might say that he was one of the main
recruiters for Wagner because he has
been extolling their successes in
Ukraine and he was also known for a very
very
um
Rogue one one might say statement
um upon the day that President Putin
announced the annexation of the lugansk
and dunas Republic he was at that at the
party that was hosted by President Putin
and he recorded the video after the
party in the presence of putting behind
him where he said we will kill we will
murder we will rape and we will plunder
as needed to achieve a victory so you
might imagine that he could well be a
target for many many different
constituencies uh highly influential
figure more than half a million
followers on Telegram and one of the
most influential and prominent military
bloggers
that is true and he was providing
semi-transparent updates from the front
line which were interesting to read even
if you totally disagree with uh with
this person's uh agenda uh so he was
very popular he was sometimes pointing
to the uh avoidables and mistakes
committed by the Russian army uh at this
point nothing is certain and it could
well be that this was a Ukrainian
operation it might also be a Russian
operation of Russian Security Services
as a false flag operation to sort of uh
consolidate the pro-war statement
sentiments in Russia I would still bet
on the fact that it is more likely to be
Ukrainian operation he was a legitimate
Target he was a an officer and an
intelligence officer and a propagandist
at the same time wouldn't the ukrainians
confine their operations to military
sites rather than a cafe in Russia's
Second City
well absolutely but this is a worth of
uh little resemblance to what we've seen
before it's a hybrid war in addition to
being a a hot War
um this Cafe uh whether or not it was
owned by pregosian the owner of Wagner
was a cafe that was used regularly as a
sort of a gathering point for Russian
cyber actors cyber Warriors that are
that are in fact targeting Ukraine's
infrastructure and other organizations
that are linked to the Wagner
organizations so whether or not this was
a purely civilian location one might
argue with that
yeah a number of different theories no
doubt will emerge before we actually
know what has happened
um he will have to say highly
influential so it'd have many uh
supporters but an easy target perhaps
well yes and he's a Target and one that
could be turned into a martyr by uh
Russia's domestic Services that's why
I'm ambivalent I'm not sure I cannot say
for certainly this is not the Russian
false flag operation
um
we will find out more details when we we
know that Russia is not the transparent
Society but at this point I expect a lot
of leaks and a lot of statements by
Russians intelligence services that
would allow us to assess whether they're
being transparent or or just providing
us with smoking with smoking mirrors
just to elaborate on that false flag
attack that is something Russia would do
but deflect the blame onto Ukraine is
that right it is correct I mean there's
been a history of the Russia's domestic
Services creating uh false like attacks
in order to sort of stimulate pro-war
sentiment a lot of talk has existed also
among Russia experts that back in the
early at the turn of the century there
was there was a serious series of
apartment bombings in Russia in Moscow
that sort of triggered the pro-war
sentiment against chechnya at the time a
lot of a lot of experts believed that
that was a certain inflicted terrorist
act in order to create such a sentiment
and thus um this this might be one of
these
deliberately targeted attack which it
looks like I mean if it's a statue that
we understand exploded that he was
presented with in this Cafe this would
be the second assassination but not on
Russian soil of a senior figure
associated with the war in Ukraine
yeah so it will be probably the second
uh and probably the first well uh
sophisticated well-performed operation
because the previous one at least from
the information that has been leaked uh
did not achieve its target the target of
the previous one was Alexander duguin
one of the lead ideologists that uh the
Russia Imperial uh State Doctrine
somebody who believes that Ukraine
should not exist whereas his daughter
who was using his car at the time who's
equally a propagandist but not in any
way as influential as her father
um or and as much as a legitimate Target
as her father would have been was killed
this however today achieved apparently
the intended target it was a statue that
was given to the Target and it exploded
and killed only him while 19 other
people have been hospitalized I
understand
we attribute to the theory this could
have been by the resistance movement in
Russia perhaps a soldier coming back
from the war in Ukraine
oh as much as one would hope that there
is an active resistance within Russia
that takes risks I think a lot of the
talk that we've seen about that are in
fact
Ukrainian operations that are presented
as local resistance so I'm afraid that
there's no organized resistance that we
have to speak about within Russia at
this point but it's your firm belief as
we speak right now that you believe it
was down to Ukraine
um it was either Ukraine or a minority
opinion in part of my brain is that it
could have been a false like FSB
operation but more likely it was Ukraine
all right well thank you very much
for your time tonight it's good to get
your thoughts we're looking at live
pictures at the scene of this Cafe in St
Petersburg it is Russia's Second City
one person died we know who that person
was the well-known Russian military
blogger Vlad Glenn tatarski died in this
blast real name Maxim fomen had more
than half a million followers on
telegram one of the most prominent of
the influential military bloggers
provided an often critical running
commentary on Russia's war in Ukraine
Pro heavily Pro Putin another 16 people
were injured in that blast we will keep
you up to date with developments